uh yeah so first of all thanks to Julia
and luuka for inviting me uh and also
thanks to puya hatami and Madu tulsani
for the collaboration and the work I'll
talk about so I'm going to talk about
algorithmic regularity for polinomial
and
applications um yeah so first I'll
introduce and give a brief motivation
and background on regular Tas you've
already seen today um then I'll talk
about our results which are new
algorithmic regular dma for polinomial
uh and then I'll briefly describe an
application which is decoding read M
codes Beyond list decoding radius for
certain structured kinds of Noise Okay
and I'll say what this means uh and
finally I'll just mention some open
problems
okay so
regularity uh at a very high level is a
notion of pseudo Randomness that allows
one to decompose a given object into a
small collection of smaller objects and
these objects appear random according to
certain statistical tests so we have
seen uh regularity in
graphs well by the way so there's this
fine print next to decompose because uh
often there are some error associated
with the decomposition and there can be
multiple types of error also associated
with the decomposition but let's leave
it at this high level for now okay so we
have seen Z's regularity Lama so this is
uh the
uh the claim that every dense graph can
be partitioned into a collection of
bounded number of pseudo randum bipar
graphs if you discount a small number of
edges in the gra and here regularity
means the following that for
every uh I mean so if you have a
bipartite graph just to be simple so a
bipartite graph is said to be regular if
for any two subsets a belonging to one
part and B belonging to the other part
the D density of edges between A and B
is roughly the same as the density
between the two parts as a whole okay so
one thing I just want to mention right
up front is that this property of
regularity it's not immediately clear
that I mean you
can uh I mean it's not true in fact that
you can
just so if you're given uh well let me
say it this way so I mean if you look at
this property right so it involves going
over all Poss subsets A and B so it
involves exponentially many choices so
so I mean it's very nonrival to try to
frame this regularity LMA
algorithmically in the sense that if we
want to actually find the collection of
pseudo random bipartite graphs in
polinomial time then it's not clear from
this definition how to go about
okay so Z regularity Lama is a
Cornerstone of extremal combinatorics
there as many applications in
combinatorics property testing in
complexity Theory and it's it's a I mean
a very
um what should I say uh I
mean I mean it's a type of idea I mean
right that you can use it to get I mean
to you can use it to show that certain
kinds of structures exist in a graph but
then then it's not immediately clear how
to actually find those structures I mean
so the same kind of thing is true also
for the Lage local LMA where you can use
it to make statements about existence of
certain structures but then finding the
structure itself is a non-trivial task
uh so the original proof is not
algorithmic and if you are familiar with
the proof of the regular it's basically
an energy argument so you find a
non-regular pair a a pair a and can be
which violates this condition and then
once you find it you use it to uh to
make to refine your existing partition
right and a certain energy quantity goes
up at every time but then the question
is how do you actually find this
certificate for non-regularity how do
you find these subsets A and B which a
prior seem to require exponential time
okay so alone atal alone Duke
leftman R and uster uh for considered
this problem and gave a polinomial Time
algorithm and then there was a whole
series of Works finally Fisher mat and
shapira gave an algorithmic O of n time
regularity LMA I'm not exactly going to
State uh the I mean I'm not going to
State the exact uh uh the exact theorem
but notice that o of n is even sublinear
in the size of the graph which could
have n Square
mines all right so what I'm going to
talk about here is concerned about
pseudo Randomness for functions over
finite Fields not graphs so we'll be
concerned in regularity lemas for
functions which map a vector space over
finite field FP to the N to the complex
numbers so let me just establish some
notation so F uh we always say f is FP
for a prime field P so some of these
questions don't make sense for uh for
non- Prime P but let me for that
question for now and then so we'll use
this notation e of x e subscript f of x
to denote this the exponential function
and then the bias of a polinomial is the
uh is the
expected uh expectation of the
exponential over all X in the domain
okay and the correlation between FNG is
measured by the inner product function
um over this field the correlation and
we'll see that a function is pseudo
random if it doesn't correlate with low
degree phase polinomial so a phase
polinomial is an exponential of a
polinomial in the classical sense which
maps from FP to the N to FP okay so
generally we'll use capital P to denote
functions which map to the field and
small letters uh like small F to denote
functions which map to the complex
numbers okay so the question is
again similar to what we did for graphs
is it possible to given a function can
we decompose
it in terms of the pseudo random
functions with functions which don't
correlate with low degree phase
pols I'll motivate why this is
interesting in a moment but let's just
see that for linear phase polinomial
this is essentially F
analysis uh so suppose you
have so a linear polinomial is a fun
function which can be written in this
way Lambda XI and so let's say P1 is the
set of linear phase polinomial so these
are exponentials of these linear
polinomial and so here it's clear that
measuring correlation with respect to uh
linear phase polinomial is just the
forier
coefficient uh so if you write so for
any function f if you write F if you
expand out F in its fora decomposition
so F Lambda had these are the for
coefficients and you are writing it in
terms of uh exponentials of linear
polinomial then we can split this sum in
this uh into two so one consisting of
for coefficients which are smaller than
some quantity and the other so smaller
than Epsilon and the other for
coefficients which are larger than
Epsilon right so what this means is that
so the F coefficients which are so this
part so the function so this function
right doesn't correlate with any
polinomial with any function in
P1 uh so the correlation with any
function in P1 is bounded by Epsilon
okay so this uses the orthogonality of
these functions okay so the so this
function has correlation at most Epsilon
with any sum over Lambda XI when Lambda
is in the sum and it has correlation
zero for any uh Lambda which doesn't
appear in this
sum so orthogonality of these expon of
the linear phase polinomial implies that
the left side is sud random and then
also notice that because we have paral
inequality which says that the sum of
the squares of the fora coefficients is
at most one we have that the number of
so if if each of these forer
coefficients is more than Epsilon the
number of terms here is at most 1 by
Epsilon squ okay so if Epsilon is a
constant we have that this is a constant
number of um is a con constant size
linear combination of linear phase pols
plus some function which does not
correlate with linear phase
Pol and also notice that this
decomposition can be made effective can
be made algorithmic using G CL so
so the celebrated theorem of gold and 11
actually gives you a way to uh find out
the so in polinomial time you can uh you
can find the F coefficients which are
large okay so we want to do a similar
thing for higher degree polinomial so
here suppose uh so let's say p d is the
set of phase polinomial for polinomial
which are of degree at most d
and the question is so this is the
question that we'll study how do we do
decomposition with respect to these set
of uh functions right so we want to take
P at most D to be the set of structured
functions and we want to write our
function so given function we want to
write it as a combination of the
structured functions and some
pseudorandom part
okay so this type of decomposition is
required in several problems in additive
combinatorics for example in property
testing some very I mean the only tests
that are known for some natural
properties uh that are known right now
go through this route of decomposing
into uh structured and sudo random
Parts uh and uh and they are also useful
in many different areas in uh I
mean combinatorial number Theory but the
main thing to notice is that so you can
can say that we can do the same type of
thing right so we can try to decompose a
given function as a sum of exponentials
of pols of degree at most D instead of
linear pols when issue that arises is
that we don't have orthogonality so you
don't have a unique F expansion as we
did in this case and so you don't
immediately get any decomposition the
okay
okay so the question is what notion of
regularity for polinomial gives near
orthogonality okay gives so ideally we
would want orthogonality but suppose
even if we are satisfied with the pooms
being nearly orthogonal what notion of
regularity do we need so green and Tow
um so we'll give a notion of regularity
which was shown to work by green and to
for high characteristics and then cman
and low show the same actually works for
low characteristics
okay okay so before I do this let me
actually make uh this notion a bit
formal
so so we are given some function
f and we want to write it in terms
of
pols but these pols
are are of degree at most
D and we claim that it's not true that
these are all orthogonal to each other
so there there's no unique decomposition
so we want to write it in terms of a
collection of polinomial which are
orthogonal to each
other okay
so so let's look at so suppose we have
some collection P1 through PC
okay this is a collection of pols of
degree atos D so first let me just
establish some nure so we'll say that
collection of pols so we'll call the
collection of pols a polinomial factor
okay so the degree of a polinomial
factor is going to be a bound on the
degree of the polinomial in the factor
and then uh this polinomial factor it's
very useful to look at it as a
partitioning of FS2 to the N into atoms
okay so what this means is
that so once you have such a collection
of
polinomial so this naturally splits the
domain into atoms such that all the pols
are constant on each of the
atoms so we can label one atom by say K1
through
KC and the atom labeled by K1 through KC
satisfies the property that this is the
collection of all the points such that
P1 of X is equal to
K1 P2 of X is equal to
K2 p c of X is equal to
KC
okay and then we say that a function is
measurable with respect to a polinomial
factor if it's constant on each atom of
the
factor
okay so when so if a function so if a
function is so if you can write a
function as a function of P1 through PC
then it will be measurable with respect
to this polomia
cut okay so so now let me get back to so
we want to so recall what we are trying
to do we are trying to define the notion
of regularity
for a collection of pols which assures
that these pols are nearly orthogonal to
each
other uh so this leads us to this notion
of rank okay so we'll say that the rank
of a polinomial p is equal to the
smallest M such that P is measurable in
a collection P1 through PM of M degreed
polinomial so in this case if you have
X1 X2 + X1 X3 and you are trying to
measure the rank with respect to D equal
to 1 then the rank is two because you
can write it as a function of two degree
one
polinomial
okay and the notion of regularity which
was introduced by green and to was that
we'll say that a polinomial factor is
regular so if the so say d is
the uh okay so it's regular
if for any C1 through CM okay
if D is the degree of the linear
combination C1 P1 plus C2 P2 through C
cmpm then we want that the rank of this
linear combination with respect to D
minus one be high okay so it shouldn't
be the case that any linear it shouldn't
be the case that you have a linear
combination of these polinomial which is
expressible as a function of strictly
lower degree
polinomial uh so
okay and the reason why we are bringing
this up is because we have this theorem
so again green and house showed this
over the high characteristic case when
the characteristic of the field is
greater than D and calman and loet
handled it generally so the claim is
that if the polinomial is biased meaning
that that the uh right so this quantity
is at least Epsilon for some nonzero
Epsilon then the rank is
bounded so this immediately means that
if you
have a factor P1 through PC which is
regular okay so again this means that
any linear combination of P1 through PC
has high rank then you immediately get
that any two linear combinations of
these pols are nearly orthogonal to each
other unless uh I mean unless you have
the same linear combination okay
right so this should be clear because
you are
taking uh so the correlation
between this function and this function
is exactly the sum of Lambda expect
exponential of sum of Lambda I Pi I
minus sum of Lambda I prime PI right so
this is some linear combination of the
pis and this
expectation is
uh so if it's high rank then we know
that the this bias is small right so if
the bias is small then this correlation
has to be
low so here rank rank because you had
rank according to rank sub some number
right rank of what
of uh so here this is just one
polinomial so the it's rank with respect
to the degree of the
polus one yeah minus
one um well
right yeah so the way it's in it's with
respect to
that
okay okay so so we have this notion rank
which leads to near orog near
orthogonality and then
also there's the other important
ingredient that if you if you have any
polinomial Factor P1 through PN then you
can refine it to a regular Factor okay
so not so in the case of
U okay right so if you think back to
what we did for linear phase polom there
we could actually just use the
definition of f coefficients in order to
get the decomposition into uh the sum of
linear phase polinomial but here we have
to work in order to get uh in order to
write a function as a function of of
polinomial in a regular Factor okay and
this proof is very easy I mean so it's
just an inductive proof so you start
with any polinomial Factor so you start
with with any collection of polinomial
and then if it's not regular it means
that there's some linear combination
which has low rank right so you find so
so so suppose P1 is involved in that
linear combination and without loss of
generality suppose P1 has the largest
degree okay and then you can just
replace P1 by the collection of lower
degree polinomial that the linear
combination can be um evaluated in terms
of and so here I mean so it's easy to
show that you get I mean so you can run
this induction so each time you're
replacing a polinomial by a collection
of strictly lower degree polinomial and
eventually this induction
stops but the point is that this process
is not
algorithmic so here you need to
find uh so in order to do this right you
need to find a low rank collection of
you need to find a linear combination
which has low rank okay so you can run
over all possible linear combinations
that's fine because we usually assume so
m is a constant but how do you actually
determine given a function whether it's
low rank or
not
um okay so we need to find low rank so
so this step is not
algorithm all
right so so just to recap so so there is
a decomposition for polinomial so the PO
so given
any so I want to make two
remarks so basically what we have shown
is that if you start from any polinomial
p
you can and suppose the degree of p is
D so you can write
p as so p is measurable so you can write
p in terms of a high rank collection of
polinomial okay so you can start with so
you can start with the collection of
pols which is just p
and then you get
to a collection of polinomial P1 through
PC which is
regular andh
sudum uh and uh and as we said so this
are these pols are nearly orthogonal so
one can just do F analysis to for
example show that P1 through PC splits
the uh splits the domain so if you look
at the partition which is given by P1
through PC it splits the splits FP to
the N into atoms which are roughly equal
in
size so one point is that this is not
algorithmic because this decomposition
into regular polins as we noticed in the
earlier slide is not algorithmic and the
second Point here is that we are
assuming that P is a polinomial okay uh
whereas if you recall in the case of
degree one functions we didn't have to
make any assumption so we started with
an arbitrary function and we could do
the for
decomposition so in the rest of the talk
I'm going to stick with polinomial but
I'm going to show how to make this
decomposition algorithmic okay so we
won't get a high rank collection of
polinomial but we'll get something else
but so our notion of pseudo and
regularity will not be what we had
earlier but again it's going to imply
that the polinomial are nearly
orthogonal to each
other okay so before we do this I just
want to make one remark about the proof
of uh of this theorem that bias implies
low
rank so the first step in both green Tow
and cman L is this LMA by bdan and Viola
it says that every biased degree D
polinomial can be approximated by a few
degree at most D minus one po
okay
uh right so the proof basically goes
right like this so recall so we want to
show that if you have a bias polinomial
then it is also a low rank polinomial so
you start with the bias polinomial then
you use bdan Viola to claim that it must
be closed to some function of low degree
polinomial okay and then after that you
refine q1 through QC to a regular Factor
q1 Prime through qm Prime and the main
theorem in both green Tow and cman lit
is that if p is approximated well enough
by a regular Factor then it is in fact
measured meable enough so measurable
means that it's not I mean you you no
longer just have that P is close to
gamma of q1 through QC but in fact p is
a function of uh q1 Prime through qm
Prime and this proof uses some strong
equid distribution properties which are
implied by regularity of Pol
okay so if we want to replace our notion
of regularity by something else then it
should satisfy two properties okay so
one should be
that
uh one remark that I want to make is
that this part the B of V this part can
be Al made algorith very easily okay so
the part that given a bias polinomial
you want to find a collection of pols
which approximates it this part can
algorithm but if we want to make the
whole thing algorithmic we need to
satisfy two things one is that the no of
regularity should imply that the that
the polinomial are orthogonal to each
other so that will imply the required
statistical properties that are needed
for applications and the second is that
we should be able to do this regular
refinement in the sense that we should
be able to do this step that if p is
approximated well enough by a regular f
for our new notion of regularity it
should still be true that we can claim
that it's in fact measurable with
respect to that factor
okay okay so let's start with this
attempt at regularity okay so this is
our new notion of regularity this is
just very
straightforwardly so first attempt is
just tries to measure correlation with
um just tries to just measures the bias
okay
so so we'll say that a function factor
is gamma unbiased if its bias is less
than then gamma of the dimension of the
factor which just means M here okay so
gamma is some function which in terms of
the size of the
factor so it's clear that if you have
such a polinomial factor which is
unbiased right then of course you
immediately get near
orthogonality that's by definition so
then the question is uh and right so and
then once you get orthogonality you also
get these nice equid distribution
properties so then so this this is the
minimal that we can start with but then
is it true that this actually suffices
right so remember what we want to do
um okay so I'll just skip ahead so so
the bad part about this definition is
that it's actually not strong enough to
imply exact computation of the of P okay
uh so the proofs by green and to and
cman and L it requires stronger equid
distribution properties of the factor
which are not implied just by
unbiasness okay uh so we need a stronger
notion of regularity and for the rest of
the talk let's assume that we are in
this High characteristic domain where
the degree is more than the
characteristic of the uh sorry degree is
less than the characteristic of the F
okay our notion of regularity will use
uh
use G Norms uh so here's the definition
of g Norm so if you have a function from
FS2 to the N to actually complex numbers
well let's say R because we don't have
conjugation here so to R then the 2 to
the K power of the G Norm is this
quantity okay so this is just measuring
the derivative of F at a random point in
K random directions okay
so you're looking at a random K
dimensional cube in fp2 and then looking
at this
one so for example for U2 for k equal to
2 we have this quantity and if you
actually stare at this hard enough
you'll realize that this is um just the
uh very related to the for coefficients
of
it
okay so the
um so we have
these right
so let me say this okay so if you have a
so if your function f is a phase
polinomial of degree atmost D okay and
uh
let me write this so if you have
uh so suppose so this direction
is uh is easy so if you have a function
which is correlated
with low degree with polinomial of
degree at most
D then it's actually straightforward
from the definition of the go Norm that
the d+1 go Norm is large so green and
Tow and B and Tow and Ziggler for the
case when p is greater than d uh showed
that the inverse is also true and this
is the inverse theorem that if you have
the if you have the G arm being larger
than some being non zero then you also
have correlation with respect to some
degree
D okay so the
reason right and uh so no of regularity
we we'll use the G so we'll say that a
factor is gamma uniform if it's the case
that the u n okay of the uh phase
polinomial
uh so we want that for all linear
combinations the U Norm should be at
most gamma of the uh of M so dimension
of the factor refers to M where K is the
degree of this linear combination so
this is strictly stronger than
unbiasness because if
the uh so if the K Norm is small if the
K G Norm is small then the one G Norm is
also small and that's in that's just the
bias of the
poly so this is a strictly stronger
notion that are than our notion of gamma
and bias and we'll show that it's
sufficient for obtaining algorithms and
it's strong enough for our application
okay so again recall that we need to
prove two things that this notion of
this new notion of regularity gamma
uniformity first of all that it allows
refinement that if you have a factor P1
through PM we can algorithmically find
um we can algorithmically find a uniform
refinement and second we want this exact
computation that if it's true that a
gamma uniform that a degreed polinomial
is approximated well by a gamma uniform
Factor then also the same the polinomial
is exactly computed by the same
factor and uh we show that both of these
are
true and this so the proof so the proof
of the second part uses strong equid
distribution results I mean so we have
some new equid distribution results for
gamma uniform pols this was shown in an
earlier work by myself Eldar Fisher
Hamed hatami puya hatami and
Sh uh so so we use the techniques here
to actually show
that uh that gamma uniformity is also
enough to imply exact computation
Okay so nice thing about Gamma
uniformity is that it's very easy to
estimate the G storm right because so
this so the G storm is an expectation
and you can uh sample the derivative at
different places in order to uh in order
to estimate the
C so this part is the one which so the
exact computation part is the part which
requires more work and uh and it turns
out that the equid distribution result
equid distribution which is implied by
gamma my uniformity is enough to imply
exact
computation okay so let me turn to
Applications okay so here is one theorem
which is immediately implied by what we
have shown so if you have a bias degree
D polinomial then we get a polinomial
Time randomized algorithm that outputs D
minus 1° Factor such that P is
measurable with respect to that factor
okay so this is immediate so you so
again first you approximate P by a
collection of polinomial P1 through PM
so this using the algorithmic version of
banola then uh as we said there's a
there's an effective procedure to refine
P1 through pm to a gamma uniform factor
and this is this part is also
algorithmic and then finally you once
you have that uh p is approximated by
uniform Factor then we know that it
actually also must be measurable with
respect to that same
factor here's a slightly stronger result
that also follows using combination of
known techniques and what we just show
so if you have a polinomial which has
high G Norm which has high D gorm so
this is a weaker assumption since the
bias is upper bounded by the
d
c so then uh there's a polinomial Time
randomized algorithm that again outputs
a factor of degree D minus one such that
P is measurable with respect to that
factor okay so
okay uh so the chain of arguments
basically goes like this so if you know
that the G Norm is large this means that
the uh that the bias of the derivative
polinomial is large and then
uh so this polinomial is biased so then
we can use our result to find a uh
degree D minus
one uh Factor such that this derivative
polinomial is measurable with respect to
that factor this can be done in
randomized polinomial time and finally
you use essentially tailor expansion to
deduce that P itself so if the if the uh
if this polinomial is uh measurable then
you can write P of X in terms of its
stal expansion and you can get Q by
making n to the D many
samples uh so you can do this in order
to also show that P
itself uh so you can basically find q
and add Q to this factor that we have
and again refine it if necessary so that
ultimately we get uh we get that P
itself is measurable with respect to
that
factor and finally let me mention our
sort of main application so this is read
moer codes so list decoding of read moer
I mean decoding of read moer codes so
read M codes are uh evaluation vectors
of degree R polinomial so of low degree
polinomial and um so we consider the
question of decoding read M codes Beyond
list decoding so what does this mean so
we have some um some string right and
suppose we know that it's correlated
with respect to a so suppose we know
that we have a bound on the distance
between the uh between the your given
string and and the reader code so now we
can try to so and this distance may be
quite large okay so we so it's in fact
larger than the list decoding radius so
we want to find out some code word which
is close to your given string okay so so
there can be exponentially many strings
in your in in the distance given but you
want to find some code word which is
within this
distance and uh so our main theorem is
that we can do this for structured noise
so what this means is that if your given
string so if your given word is also a
polinomial so it's a degree d polinomial
for D larger than K okay so we are
concerned with read M codes of order K
and you're given uh you're given
something which is a polinomial of
degree D more than
K so if you know that the distance
between p and
Q uh so if you know that P agrees with Q
on at least 1 by f plus Epsilon many 1
by f plus Epsilon fraction of places
then we can find a degree K polinomial
such
that find the degre Pol QA such that P
and QA agree on 1 by f plus Delta many
Delta fraction of places where Delta
depends on
Epsilon the point here is that the
radius of uh the the list recording
radius of read M codes is 1 - K by F
shown by for gopalan so the point is
that here the distance is much larger so
here it would be like 1 - 1 by F okay so
the distance is much larger than the
list decoding radius yet we can find
some degree K polinomial which lies
within that
distance
uh of course with this caveat that P
itself is a low degree Pol
and the running time of this algorithm
is n to the D where D is the degree of
of
P so it could be I mean there could be
an algorithm which runs in N to the K
okay but we don't have
one so let me just sketch a bit of the
proof so again you start with this that
the that P and Q agree with agree on at
least 1 by f plus Epsilon fraction of
places and then so you use f analysis to
show that you can convert this to a
correlation lower
B so uh so this is straightforward so if
you know that probability of P equal to
Q is at least 1 by f plus Epsilon you
can show that there exists some nonzero
t such that TP and TQ is also at least
Epsilon for some degree k polinomial
q so now of course we have
that okay so if the correlation is large
with some degree k polinomial then the U
K plus one Norm of TP is also large so
it means that since D is greater than K
the D Norm of u d Norm of TP is large
now we do foror analysis on TP
okay first of all we write TP using our
algorithmic regularity LMA we write TP
in terms of P1 through pm and P1 through
PM is this gamma uniform uh Factor where
gamma is chosen to be sufficiently small
and once you you do F analysis so again
we have Fier coefficients so some of
these Fier coefficients involve
pols which are which whose degree is at
most
K and these are these are greater than K
and you use the fact that these
polinomial are nearly orthogonal to each
other to deduce that
this uh so this part has small UK + one
n so again we have degree Atmos and this
part has small UK + 1
n
uh right uh
okay oh so sorry so the small UK + one
Norm
is uh is immediate okay so once you get
this then you can use near orthogonality
to show that c Lambda there has to be
some Lambda such that c Lambda is large
and C Lambda lies in this this part okay
so again so right so you know that these
are orthogonal to each other and you
also have this information that the G
Norm of the whole thing is
large and then okay so one so right so
you deduce that there is some Lambda
such that c Lambda is large and then you
can find it and then since this is
basically F analysis you can find the
large Lambda using the gold 11 theorem
since C Lambda measures correlation with
this polinomial we know that we have TP
correlates with this polinomial for this
Lambda
right and then from there
it's right so once you know that your
polinomial TP so this is a constant
multiple of the given polinomial so it
correlates with these polinomial which
are of strictly lower degree then you
can show that basically a constant shift
of 1 / T * this
polinomial
suffices so the constant shift of this
has agrees with p on at least 1 / f plus
Delta fraction
of okay uh so I'll end by mentioning
these two problems uh
so here we looked at read I mean the
last application was decoding read M
codes in this in the high characteristic
case so it be interesting to have the
same result also in the low
characteristic case and the most
challenging problem here is that the we
assume that the function that we have a
polinomial right that P is a degrey
polinomial but if you have a some
arbitrary function then can you again
make this be algorithmic so this is a
very challenging problem because the
this inverse
theorem so the inverse theorem for
uh the general inverse theor not for
polinomial but for arbitrary functions
in the high characteristic case uses
aroic Theory and uh in the low
characteristic case also uses techniques
which are not aable to being made
combinatorial so so this is wide open at
the moment whether you can do read M
decoding beyond the list coding radius
for
arbitrary
functions and uh of course I mean if we
have this then we would really have an
explicit algorithmic version of the
inversor implies low
r
does it
imply high
rank so high ranking place uniform if
you then you are low rank um but I think
the comp is also true if a is low rank
it has
lar so as far as we know high rank is a
strictly is uh Stronger condition I mean
is a stronger condition
than uh gamma
uniformity cor with the L pols then you
have
be maybe
not
not with the
same right so I think you can you can
detect now how good whether you're r or
not
right right I mean so going through this
formulation but I'm not sure directly
whether you
can I think a if you are if you're low
rank then you must correlate on
your
right
uh right but uh
okay
okay yeah just a comment the list coding
radi read it's not really okay the thing
you mentioned is an upper B okay
yeah but right yeah I mean but the there
are exponential many so the point I was
trying to make is that they're
exponentially
yeah as far as I
know I mean at the expense of I mean but
don't have a because he knows this
function is a polinomial right it's not
a general
function
okay yeah I mean there is a posibility
we
don't a Conant
pols eval
coefficient right so you can explicitly
get the polom
uh right but then
okay and gold R 11
takes more
question thank you very
much